the thing that got you to quit your job
is the very thing that you have to stop
doing when you're self-employed you take
complete control you hunt you kill you
produce you do everything and then you
now have to unlearn that and you have to
say now I'm going to give up control
again and then the rest of the journey
is unlearning the control that you so
hardcore rewarded for in that first
action because in the beginning you have
to give up doing production or doing
admin work doing sale doing marketing
doing management then you have to give
up doing leadership you have to give up
all these things until eventually you're
like but I'm not needed because many
people make their business to fulfill
personal desires it doesn't exist for
you it exists for the customer